most law states that the number of
transistors in an integrated circuit
doubles every two years this is fairly
evident with the current CPU and GPU
Trends in the market the Deep learning
processor Vapor scale Engine 2 by Sarah
brass has 2.6 trillion mosfetes in 84
exposed fields on a wafer manufactured
using tsmc's 7nm fin effective process
obviously maintaining an infrastructure
of such state of the earth Computing
systems takes a lot of skilled Workforce
and plethora of resources cloud
computing provides you an alternative
where you rent resources from a
third-party service provider and pay
them a monthly or yearly amount based on
either the number of resources used or
standard fee but how do you think the
entire Cloud infrastructure is built to
support such demanding processing needs
well several Cloud providers provide the
customers with over 99.9 uptime in their
slas this means that they give their
customers a guaranteed uptime for all
the services 99.9 of the time that's
just as fascinating as it Minds
bloggling so if you're interested in
knowing more about cloud computing
infrastructure and how the entire Cloud
architecture is built to support such
demanding SLA then make sure to stay
with us until the end of this video as
we will discuss everything about cloud
computing from interviews to on job
tasks knowing thoroughly about the
architecture will definitely help and
give you an added Advantage so without
any further Ado let's get started and if
you're craving a more Hands-On detailed
approach to cloud computing then simply
learns Catholic post-graduate program in
cloud computing is the perfect fit for
you this comprehensive program will
Empower you with the Knowledge and
Skills necessary to navigate the cloud
landscape with confidence dive deep into
Cloud architecture deployment models
security and migration strategies gain
expertise in the leading Cloud platforms
such as Amazon web services Microsoft
Azure and Google Cloud platform so don't
miss out on this incredible opportunity
to transform your career and join the
ranks of successful cloud computing
professionals click the link in the
description to explore more about this
course also do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to get
notifications of more such interesting
video so let's get started with the
video but before first let's understand
what exactly is cloud computing well
imagine a vast network of powerful
computers spread across the globe
working together to deliver Computing
resources and services over the Internet
this network is commonly referred to as
the cloud cloud computing is a model
where Computing Services like storage
and applications are accessed over the
Internet it eliminates the need for
local servers and allows on-demand
access to resources it offers benefits
such as cost savings scalability
accessibility reliability and security
cloud computing has revolutionized the
way we store process and access data it
has become the backbone of modern day
technology in enabling businesses and
individuals to scale their operations
enhance collaboration and drive
Innovation but have you ever wondered
how the architecture of cloud computing
actually works well one to know more as
we uncover its Secrets today now let's
take a closer look at the architecture
of cloud computing at its core cloud
computing is the delivery of Computing
Services over the internet instead of
relying on local hardware and
infrastructures users can tap into vast
pools of remote Computing resources but
where do these resources come from let's
take a closer look well the architecture
of cloud computing typically consists of
three main layers infrastructure as a
service platform as a service and
software as a service these layers build
upon each other creating a robust and
flexible ecosystem so let's start at the
foundation with iaas that means
infrastructure as a service iaas that
means infrastructure as a service
provides the fundamental building blocks
of cloud computing offering virtualized
Hardware resources such as virtual
machines storage and networking it gives
users the freedom to manage and control
the infrastructure while eliminating the
need for physical servers some popular
IES provide us include Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform moving up the cloud
computing pyramid we reach platform as a
service now this layer provides a
platform for developers to build deploy
and manage applications without the need
to worry about the underlying
infrastructure platform as a service
offers tools libraries and Frameworks
that streamlines the development process
increasing efficiency and productivity
examples of platform as a service
providers include Heroku Microsoft Azure
app service and Google app engine
finally we reach the Pinnacle of cloud
computing architecture software as a
service now this sled delivers fully
functional software applications over
the Internet accessible through a web
browser or dedicated client software as
a service eliminates the need for users
to install and maintain software locally
providing convenience and scalability
well-known software as a service
providers include Salesforce Dropbox
Google workspace now that we have
explored the layers of cloud computing
architecture let's take a peek behind
the scenes and discover the incredible
infrastructure that powers it all behind
every cloud computing service lies a
vast network of data centers spread
across the globe these data centers
house thousands of servers storage
systems and networking equipment they're
designed with redundancy security and
scalability in mind ensuring that your
data is always available and protected
data centers consume enormous amounts of
energy and in recent years there has
been a significant push towards
sustainability Tech giants like Google
and Microsoft have made substantial
investments in renewable energy source
aiming to reduce their carbon footprint
and make cloud computing more
eco-friendly cloud computing has
transformed the way we do business
enabling startups and Enterprises alike
to scale rapidly and compete in the
digital age it has also paved the way
for exciting Technologies like
artificial intelligence big data and The
Internet of Things So as we wrap up this
journey into the architecture of cloud
computing let's reflect on the
remarkable impact it has had on our
lives from storing our precious memories
to powering the applications we rely on
daily the cloud has become an integral
part of our digital existence
so to help you better understand the
impact of cloud computing and upskilling
in this field it was a success story of
one of our Learners that will help you
build your belief and boost your
confidence to master this technology so
let's start hi I am I live in Mumbai and
I am the co-founder and chief digital
and Technology officer of vcns global I
wanted to cater to customers who wanted
to take the journey towards the cloud so
I decided to opt for the post graduation
program in cloud computing in
association with Caltech from Simply
learn so I was learning every day and
implementing my learning at my business
after I completed the course I was able
to structure the whole Cloud consultancy
vertical for my company I think it was a
wise decision to take the course and
business time is money so make a wise
investment today well thank you for
joining us today we hope you found this
exploration into the architecture of
cloud computing as fascinating as we did
if you like this video then please do
give it a thumbs up and share it with
your friends and if you have any
questions then please feel free to ask
away in the comment section our team
will reach out to you as soon as
possible till then thank you and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign